je vais utiliser ce temps de
d'explication de vote pour quand même
mentionner une situation que j'ai
rarement vu dans cette hémicycle y
compris dans les grands moments de très
longues discussions sur des réformes
importantes
il y a eu un millier d'amendements qui
ont été proposés ici des battus et
proposer par l'opposition de gauche
pas un seul n'a été voté positivement
pas un seul n'a reçu un avis positif oui
je m'impose parce que
sur toutes les autres lois
on se dit ici qu'on est fier très
souvent sur des désaccords très
importants sur des lois entre la gauche
et la droite qu'il y a un enrichissement
c'est-à-dire que il y a des amendements
de la gauche qui viennent ajouter
préciser quelque chose et ce geste là
cette façon de faire la loi nous permet
non seulement d'élever le débat
démocratique mais de montrer un respect
mutuel j'accuse surtout le gouvernement
parce que on peut prendre plein de
moments où vous auriez pu faire ces
signes là de de bonnes pratiques
démocratiques
que ce soit sur l'index senior il y
avait énormément d'abandon moi j'en ai
par exemple proposé un qui était de
mettre dans l'index une spécification
sur les personnes handicapées vous êtes
contre non mais fallait pas surtout
faire ce signe à l'opposition et surtout
les taux vous dites oui vous voulez
taxer toutes les entreprises celles qui
font des dizaines de milliards comme
celles qui font quelques millions mais
prenez celle sur les dizaines de
milliards choisissez de nous donner gré
que quand on fait des dizaines de
milliards de bénéfices et que il y a des
dividendes importants et bien vous vous
pouvez faire ce geste
je conclure en vous disant simplement
que je veux à ce moment la dire que dans
ce débat vous êtes dans une opposition
frontale avec la